anthony diesclefani makes the start
tonight for cincinnati he hasn't started
since august 21st because he was back
home in new jersey for the birth of his
son crew good speed at second base in
tommy edmond and now paul goldschmidt
diese klefani from the belt the pitch
goldie lines it to right field to base
it that's going to score edmond as the
ball is picked up on the warning track
by castianos and goalie moves into
second with an rbi double one nothing
cardinals in the first inning at great
american ball park paul deyoung 11 for
his last 27 he had a pair of three hit
games
against the cleveland indians payoff
pitch
strike three call back-to-back punch
outs looking right over the outside
corner to paul deyoung he's punched out
back-to-back strikeouts for anthony d
stefani cardinals turned to dakota
hudson who's pitched very well each time
out and he was at his best last time he
got stretched out to six innings now
eugenio suarez stands in 174 seven
homers and 15 runs batted in
and now the 1-1
into center field line drive will fall
in front of the center fielder here
comes bottom to the plate we are tied at
one
indeed a clutch two out hit from suarez
in steps yadier molina here's the 2-2 to
molina and he weakly grounds one toward
third charging hard suarez barehand pick
throw on the run close and out at first
base molina
give molina credit he was hustling down
the line
and the cardinals need a two-out hit
here
from colton wong
the o2
puts it in play slap the other way for a
base hit he comes through with two outs
two to one cardinals carpenter touches
home plate with the redbirds second run
there's a two out rbi for colton so
runners at first and second and now
tommy edmond
one-two pitch
[Applause]
gonna have to hurry bottom flipped to
diesel funny
and the ending over for the cardinals
akiyama's average up to 202 no homer's
three rbis japanese baseball last year
303 with 20 home runs 82 rbis and he
slashes the ball colton wong to his
right kept it for going into center
field and throws him out the gold glover
shows us why
and the cardinals have
two on with one out that'll bring up
yada year molina
and yachty jumps on that pitch it's well
hit out to left plenty deep aquino will
make the catch
runners will tag up
goldschmidt will score
and deyoung is in safely
and that'll make it a 3-1 st louis lead
first and third two outs the eight
batter dexter fowler
here's the 2-0 pitch
and fowler lifts a fly ball to left
sinking quickly but it'll hang up for
aquino to come in and make the catch and
the inning is over the cardinals get one
more then casteano stands in base is
empty two outs next pitch to castillano
swinging a miss he struck him out so he
gets barnhard vano and castellanos what
an inning for dakota hudson one two
three he made that look easy
base is loaded 3-1 cardinals
we are in the fourth with two outs a
chance for de young to break it open
here
there go the runners and
the young sends one out to deep center
field akiyama back gone
grand slam paul de young
his first grand slam in the big leagues
on a 3-2 pitch sends it out to center
field and the grand slam for the
cardinal shortstop
aquino is still coming to the plate
with frank sinatra
as his walk-up song
in the run one strike pitch aquino hits
it hard on the ground to colton wong
nice pick and he throws out aquino one
out
one out shoko akiyama to the plate
grounded out the second baseman his
first time up chokes the bad an inch or
two the pitch a swing and a ground ball
right back to hudson while moving toward
first hudson he gloves it underhands and
akiyama is out number two one three on
that two guard and the batter is paul
deyoung
1-2 pitch
nice work by lorenzo one out for nick
castiano's castiano's is over two
here's the 2-0 pitch castianos bounces
it to the left side matt carpenter will
take a step to his left glove and throw
in time to first get the out on
castiano's barnhart is home from third
to score
the red's second run tonight it's now
seven and two cardinals
and that'll bring jesse winker to the
plate
now on two and one the pitch by hudson
hit hard up the middle picked by the
shortstop and de young throws him out
with three infielders on the right side
the young moved to his left to close the
gap in between wong and deyoung and with
the shift on the cardinal shortstop
throws out winker two outs and nobody
aboard here's aristide's aquino
hudson looking to finish seven innings
of work for only the second time in his
career
away from bush stadium the one-two pitch
here it comes swinging a miss strikeout
number seven dakota hudson
outstanding game for the cardinal
right-hander who is through seven
and the cardinals enjoying
a 7-2
bader was starting to get into a good
rhythm at the play too and the the
migraine hit
[Applause]
what a pick by suarez
[Applause]
not in time and it looks like they did
get him the reds are challenging this
call
because the umpires
take the headsets off they remove those
overturned the call out at first bader
now with two on and one out the batters
a eugenio suarez
deal one to suarez he swings sits this
one high in the air deep right center
field bader going back on the warning
track leaps at the wall it is gone
hey eugenio suarez gets it out of here
to right center field and all of a
sudden
it's seven to five cardinals
and with only one out of the ninth
inning it's a two run game
eugenio suarez with his eighth home run
of the year
now aristides aquino will come to the
plate
with the bases empty and two away
now 102 the pitch
slang and a miss a red bird winner in
cincinnati